so I got vox popped and it's gone viral
I'll tag Connor below but there are threads
talking about whether me and my boyfriend are arguing in the vox pop
and talking about whether or not he's a Trump supporter
it's so funny to me so we're having this exchange and um
he asked me do you wanna go first
and I just launch into absolutely as a woman
men should shut the hell up about it
and he just steps aside and the camera just pans towards me
it comes across really harsh and intense
but people are getting their knickers in and on about it
so I just wanna set the record straight on this interaction
is my boyfriend a Trump supporter
hell no he said
as a woman you should go first
you should speak on this he said that in order to make a point
he didn't let his ego get in the way of making a feminist point
we both knew that it was for the camera and we both knew it was theatre
and we both know that a lot of the time politics is theatre
so this was all to make that point
we know each other so well
he knew what I would do I knew what he would do
neither of us is upset or offended
and we've been cackling about it
people are saying oh
they've argued about this
like her boyfriend must be a Trump supporter
um you know
you can just tell they had an argument about it
um we've had discussions about it and we're both completely on the same page
he is a complete socialist
so he doesn't really like most people in politics
but in terms of Trump he knew that as someone with a uterus um
my views were a little more poignant
and a little more relevant in this particular case
and he didn't need to be asked twice
he stepped right aside and I wouldn't expect anything less of a man
of a man I choose to be with
he knows that in the moment
my anger at saying shut up
was directed towards Trump
and towards the men on the internet
has been saying horrific things on behalf of survivors
and on behalf of women and trans people everywhere
he knew my ankle was directed at that situation and not at him
he's disgusted that Trump was elected
he's disgusted by what's been happening on the internet
and he wholeheartedly supports everything that I said